hello and welcome to the chichi science
show so
nature aging officially launched last
week and so in this video i thought i'd
discuss
one of their a few topics intermittent
and periodic fasting
longevity and disease and so this review
was primarily written
by folta longu who's been researching
the role of fasting for a long time
and so in this video we'll begin by
looking at the different types of
fasting
and address the underlying molecular
mechanisms that happen when you fast
and then we'll look at some of the
animal models and then go into some of
the human data
that shows the impact of different
fasting regimens
and lastly i want to go into a bit more
detail about the importance of
re-feeding and the role of stem cells
after the fasting periods and how this
might be important
in terms of understanding the
differences in efficacy between
intermittent and periodic fasting
and also briefly we'll take a look at
how diet composition is also important
so there's lots of information to jump
into in this video
but firstly i just want to make a quick
disclaimer that i'm not trying to
suggest the fasting methods described
here
and you should definitely consult your
doctor before trying anything
the aim of this video is merely for a
discussion not practical advice
so first then what is fasting and what
is the difference between intermittent
and periodic fasting so in humans
fasting is achieved by ingesting
none or a minimal amount of foods for
periods that can range from 12 hours
up to 3 weeks and so fasting is very
different to calorie restriction
which is when the daily caloric intake
is reduced chronically
by 20 to 40 and it's also very different
to starvation
which is chronic nutritional
insufficiency so what's the difference
between
intermittent fasting and periodic
fasting well they differ
mainly in the duration of the fast so
for intermittent fasting
these are much shorter time periods
which can range from 12 hours
in time-restricted feeding up to a
24-hour fast
seen in alternate day fasting and
intermittent fasting also includes the
5-2 diets
whereby there's a five-day eating period
with a two-day fast or two days where
there's a very low calorie consumption
and so as you can see in this table here
there are a variety of different
intermittent fasting diets and so in
contrast
periodic fasting refers to a prolonged
and severely calorie
or water-only fasting periods lasting in
most cases between
48 hours in a week but longer time
periods up to 21 days have been
investigated
and so the key difference between
periodic fasting and intermittent
fasting
is that periodic fasting can occur at
specific intervals
or like a kind of as needed basis and is
usually carried out less than once
every two weeks and the two major
methods of periodic fasting
include a water-only periodic fast or a
so-called fasting mimicking diet
that was originally tamed by filter
which is a plant-based caloric
restricted diet containing low proteins
low sugar and high unsaturated fats
that are able to mimic the same effects
as fasting only with water
so what are these effects well the major
source of energy in our bodies is
glucose
and the majority of glucose is stored in
our liver where it is stored as glycogen
when there's increased physical activity
or at the onset
of a fast this liver glycogen gets
broken down into glucose that's so that
it can be used as a fuel of energy
once the liver glycogen is depleted
other sources are used instead
this includes pyruvate and fat derived
glycerol and
amino acids that occur in a process
known as gluconeogenesis
and then as the fasting continues there
is the breakdown of fatty acids for
energy
and this breakdown of fatty acids is
referred to as
ketogenesis and effectively it's a
metabolic pathway that produces
so-called ketone bodies
which is an alternative form of energy
for the body and so during fasting there
effectively is a metabolic switch
from liver-derived glucose to adipose
derived ketone bodies
and so typically the level of ketone
bodies in plasma is around
100 to 250 micromolars however this can
increase up to one millimolar during a
prolonged fast however due to the acidic
nature of the ketone bodies
acetyl acetate and beta hydroxybutyrate
the high levels of ketone bodies around
20 millimolars
can result in keto acidosis which is not
something that you want
so why would there potentially be
benefits from fasting
well this alternative metabolic pathway
is thought to
be focused more on being able to
conserve energy
and to protect the organism while
enduring extended periods of food
deprivation
and this is to optimize survival and
reproduction once food becomes available
again
in terms of the molecular mechanisms a
reduction in the amino acids and glucose
present
reduces the signaling through mtor known
as
the mammalian target of rapamycin that
promotes
growth within a cell moreover a
reduction in glucose reduces signaling
through the rast pathway
that also promotes growth in addition to
amino acids and glucose
insulin levels also reduce during
fasting along with igf-1
which is the insulin like growth factor
moreover
indirect effects of fasting alter the
ratio of different metabolites
including the ratio of coenzyme to
acetyl coa
nadplus to nadh and amp
to atp and these metabolites can affect
directly or indirectly the epigenetic
marks within a cell
for example it can increase search one
activity due to an increase in the
levels of nad plus
and this can instead promote the nacelle
stress resistance pathways
along with an up regulation of
progeostasis and autophagy
and so this all helps enable cells to be
able to survive
when nutrients are scarce and instead
help to recycle
and repair damaged cellular components
and so reasons why this might be
beneficial
comes in line with all of the previous
data i've spoken about in this channel
regarding different potential
supplements
such as rapamycin that inhibits mtor
along with resveratrol that activates
sertoins such as cert-1
and nad-plus precursors that also
help to increase certain one activity
and inhibiting or activating these
different proteins
have been shown in a variety of
different mortal organisms to have
beneficial impacts in terms of both
health span and lifespan
i'd say maybe unsurprisingly then this
metabolic switch that occurs during
fasting
and its alteration in the intracellular
signaling pathways
has been shown in studies to extend
lifespan of bacteria
yeast worms and mice and so this review
article doesn't really touch on these
different supplements
but i will briefly talk about them at
the end and their implications with
fasting
in particular in terms of the re-feeding
process so now let's take a look more
specifically
at the benefits of fasting and in
particular try and try to compare
between
intermittent fasting and periodic
fasting
and interestingly um sachin panda is
in my mind one of the major researchers
in terms of intermittent fasting
whereas volta lungo seems to focus more
on his research on periodic fasting
styles just sound interesting anyway so
i initially
learned about fasting by reading the
circadian code by sachin pandor
and so he talks a lot about
time-restricted feeding which is one of
these forms of intermittent fasting
and so understanding the benefits of
that tries to bring in the
importance of food timing with the
circadian rhythm
and how different processes within our
bodies happen at certain times of the
day
and how eating plays into that and the
study that
always comes to mind when i think about
the benefits of time-restricted feeding
is this cell metabolism paper
time-restricted feeding without reducing
calorie intake prevents metabolic
diseases in mice fed in a high-fat diet
so despite eating the same amount of
calories mice on the time-restricted
feeding diets
whereby they were eating for eight hours
per day were protected against
obesity hyperinsulinema inflammation and
they also had improved motor
coordination
compared to mice that were just eating
adlibitum and they're going to show that
this effect was potentially mediated
by enhanced oscillations of the
circadian clock and the target gene
expression and so given the beneficial
effects seen in this study they then
went and studied
time-restricted feeding in patients with
metabolic syndrome
and they also showed similar cardiac
metabolic benefits
for example the time restricted feeding
prevented excessive body weight gain
improved sleep and attenuated age and
diet induced deterioration in cardiac
performance
and it also improved blood pressure a
different study that looked at the
benefits of the 5-2
intermittent fasting diet showed that
comparing overweight women that either
followed the 5-2 diet or a 25
calorie restricted diet they lost the
same amount of weight
but those in the 5 2 diet had a greater
increase in insulin sensitivity
so there seems to be reported benefits
of intermittent fasting
however there's also studies that do
suggest that the risk of gallstone
disease
nearly doubles between women who fast
for eight hours per day
and those who fast for over 14 hours per
day although this study is quite old and
was quite a small sample size
however it should definitely be further
investigated
moreover another study showed that
skipping breakfast which could be used
as a way of following time-restricted
feeding
is associated with an increased risk of
mortality from cardiovascular and
all-course mortality in the u.s
population
i say more on from that it would be very
interesting to understand
how time-restricted feeding benefits can
vary depending on whether the feeding
occurred
during the morning or evening so whether
or not breakfast time
or dinner time was effectively skipped
and i find this most fascinating because
if the benefits of time-restricted
feeding are supposed to be acting
through the circadian rhythm then i
think it 100
makes sense for there to be some
difference between whether or not
the feeding occurs in the morning or
evening but i really couldn't find any
data on that
so i have nothing to say other than the
fact that i tend to eat in the morning
but who knows maybe i'm doing it wrong
so anyway let's now take a look at some
of the effects of periodic fasting on
aging
and i'm actually going to focus a little
bit more on the fast mimicking diets as
opposed to
water only periodic fasting only due to
the fact that
periodic fasting where only water is
consumed
has a lot more safety concerns in
particular with those who are already
malnourished
as it can lead into well malnourishment
but also rapid weight loss reduced blood
pressure and hypoglycemia
and the exacerbation of existing
micronutrients deficiencies and so this
is why fast mimicking diets were
developed as they can also
promote the effects of fasting while
standardizing dietary composition
providing nourishment and minimizing the
burden and these different side effects
that can be seen
with water only fasting and so this
takes us back to a paper that came out
in 2015 from falters lab
a periodic diet that mimics fasting
promotes multi-system regeneration
enhance cognitive performance and health
span and so this
fmd this fast-moving diet that was low
in calories and protein
and was fed to the mice starting at six
months of age
for four days twice a month and in
between these different fasting periods
they were eating ad libitum and so the
mice on this diet displayed an 11
increase in their median lifespan in
addition to significant weight and
visceral fat loss
but without losing muscle mass and they
also showed that it reduced tumor
incidence by 45
and what they also saw in the mice was
that although they were calorie
restricted during the diet
they compensated for the restriction by
overeating
in the ad libertarian period and falter
goes on to say in this review article
about the importance of the potential
importance of this refeeding process
as it seems the cycles of fasting and
then re-feeding
are powerful promoters of stem cell cell
renewal mechanisms
and activators of tissue regeneration in
part through inhibition
and reactivation of igf-1 and
mtor pathways so the idea that you first
inhibit these pathways
to promote stress resistance and then
when food
returns those pathways get suppressed
and growth pathways instead get
signaling
that allows the regeneration of new
tissue
and the evidence for this that was shown
in this 2015 paper by photo is nicely
summarized in this review figure where
by the fmd diet affected tissue
regeneration
in immune cells bone cells brain cells
muscle cells pancreatic cells as well as
in the intestine
and it's thought that this regeneration
in part helps to extend the health span
of these mice
because it protects the mice against
age-related decline in these different
tissues
but the important question or at least
well for me the thing that i find
interesting is how this is happening
is the changes in the metabolic
signaling having epigenetic changes
or is it changing the stem cell niche
which regulates the activity of the stem
cells
and so as folta says the role of
regeneration during the refeeding period
is poorly understood and should be
investigated further in multiple tissues
and the other reason why i think that
this is quite interesting in addition to
just
understanding the importance of fast
mimicking diets
is due to the fact that these different
supplements that have been shown to
extend
lifespan in different muscle organisms
such as rapamycin
and resveratrol these are acting to
inhibit the signaling through these
growth pathways
and so what if it's the case that the
best thing to do is to have
periods of inhibition of grave signaling
followed by activation so actually
trying to activate mtall signaling
although i guess the best way to do that
really is just by food but yeah
interesting questions um we shall have
to await answers
and i didn't say but there have been
human studies that have looked into the
impact of fmd
for example in one study there was a
randomized clinical trial with a hundred
relatively healthy volunteers that used
fmd cycles lasting five days
carried out once per month for three
months and it was shown to reduce
multiple risk factors for age-related
diseases
including diabetes cancer and
cardiovascular disease
however i'm going to emphasize what
falter says in this review that although
fmds appear to be safe
their use should be limited to three
times per year in healthy people with
normal levels of disease risk factors
until additional and long-term clinical
studies demonstrating the safety of more
frequent use are carried out
and so this comes back to another
question of which fasting mechanism
would potentially be more effective
periodic fasting such as fmd or
intermittent fasting such as time
restricted feeding
and the thing is we don't really know
enough about irithm or have enough
studies to be able to directly compare
them
and maybe i've potentially been swayed
by falters
biased opinions on fmd diets it does
seem very interesting this refeeding
process
and so maybe there is some truth and the
fact that
these more severe fasting refeeding
do have a better kind of stop-start
action
on the regenerative processes as opposed
to chronic
time-restricted feeding but again we
just don't have the answers yet
and the other area where researchers
really required is also looking at
the age dependent differences in these
different fasting approaches
in a different to different sex
dependent differences in particular for
females
and menstruation but also also pregnancy
of well i don't think it would be
advisable to do it during pregnancy
and the other thing that's worth
mentioning is diet composition
whilst it's been well established that
low protein seems to be beneficial for
longevity this may only be true up to a
certain age whereby
low protein is actually negative and has
adverse consequences
for health span and the other thing
worth investigating would be
how supplements interact with different
fasting approaches as i mentioned
earlier so with that i hope this
has given you some good insight into
this review it was quite long and i
probably have condensed it quite a lot
but i hope i've given you the main key
take-homes from it so as always shout
out to my patreon
tina and of course all my other patrons
i'm very grateful for your contributions
and i hope you've learned something and
thanks for listening